(audience clapping)
- Over the years,
you've written so many amazing lyrics.
So I want to ask you
about some of the lyrics,
- [Kelly] if that's okay?
- Yes, Ma'am.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I was going to do it anyway, but okay.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
Millions of people love
this song, Ever long,
so on it,
you wrote and okay,
you see, we have favorites here.
"And I wonder, when I sing along with you,
if everything could ever
feel this real forever,
if anything could ever
be this good again."
I love that lyric.
I feel like there's so much in it for me.
And it's interesting.
You're gonna tell me something
and then I'm going to tell
you what I take from it.
Cause I feel like it might be different,
but, where were you when you
kind of emotionally, mentally
when you wrote that?
- Well, that was a long time ago,
but I was uh
I was in love
and one of the
one of the things that I loved so much
about uh this person,
was when we would sing together
- [Kelly] Oh
- and you know, I mean, it's
meant to sort of represent
that moment,
where...
all moments are fleeting,
but if you could be in that moment
and think like,
think like
if anything could be this good, again.
- I find that there's always
like something beautiful.
Like this lyric.
There's always something so
magical that you're like,
oh my God, such elation.
But there's also that darkness of like,
the fleeting.
So for me,
like listening to your
lyrics and maybe that's me,
not you as me reading into it, but it's,
it's one of those things.
I find a lot of your lyrics that I love.
It's that beautiful, like learns,
fly, like all these songs,
like it's like this beautiful,
like, oh, elation, this,
this beautiful moment that
you're so happy you get to have.
And you, you are so lucky to have felt,
but then that knowledge, that,
that doesn't last forever is
like, and it's so fleeting.
So I'm dark. So that's.
- I think music is meant to heal. Right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So one of the things about um,
a song uh that you connect with,
like you find yourself in the song,
or you can relate to the lyric
or you relate to the pain.
So um,
you know,
it's the luxury of my life is
that I can sit down with an
instrument and write a song
and then go out and play in
front of a bunch of people.
And they sing it with me and
it could be 50,000 people
singing the same lyric for
50,000 different reasons,
because that lyric means
something specific to them.
Like they're not singing
it for my reasons.
They're singing it for their
reasons. And so, you know,
there's something about
even the darkest lyrics.
Like I think that they're
meant to heal somehow.
There's like hope, you know,
it's important to be hopeful.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so in a lot of the
songs that I write, um
- There's that juxtaposition
for me, that's what I love.
- Right. I mean, it's like,
you're fighting your
way through something,
but you're hopeful like times,
like these are best to
do something like that.
(crowd clapping)
- Agreed, agreed.
One of your most popular
songs is learned to fly.
I love it.
You wrote on it looking
to the sky to save me,
looking for a sign of life,
looking for something to
help me burn out bright.
Now this is, once again,
it comes back to that whole
thing that I love that you do
for me, whenever I'm
listening to your lyrics,
maybe you didn't read it
like this, but I love that,
that storing feeling
like that whole thing,
I get like visually, I
always love your lyrics too.
Cause it's like paint. You paint
such a great visual for me.
And I love that,
but it kind of, again, to me is like,
a little dark and a little light.
It's always there like a shared world,
which I guess is life.
- I don't want to burst your bubble.
- Okay. I'm going to drink my tea.
And you're like, so this was.
- At the time I wanted to become a pilot.
I would like, I wanted
to learn like fly, I did
I mean like that's it like
I was, I was like, I was,
I hate that.
(Kelly screaming)
I'm sorry.
I got,
- O my god
- video tapes..
- [Kelly] It's so literal. -It really is,
- [Kelly] so literal.
I'm sorry.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, and in my brain...
- It's wat I'm talking about.
- I'm seeking it because I want
to learn how to be a pilot.
- [Kelly] In my brain.
You're singing it because I
got so inspired by whatever.
(crowd laughing)
See.
(crowd clapping)
- [Kelly] O my god.
- I want it to fly. And
then I was like, wait,
there's math involved. I can't do this.
(kelly laughing)
- Oh God, here's the thing.
I also want to be a pilot,
I actually do I still have I'm
I'm about to install my
thing that I had natural,
but I want to get my pilot's license.
My ex is a pilot and I think it's amazing.
- Yes.
- It feels to me, I'm terrified,
when I did lessons
and I was like a little
terrified up there.
So I do get that.
- You went up and like flew stuff.
- Oh. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
- Why aren't we not best friends?.
- I don't know,
- What is happening right know?
- I don't know but I have a
simulator, a flight simulator,
if you ever want to take lessons.
But I love that. I was like, oh my gosh.
So like what I was feeling,
and then you were like,
so it was just like
about being a pilot. So..
- I know.
- (kelly laughing)
- Sorry
- I am tool.
So, but it is funny how we, like,
somebody will come up to
me and I'm like, whoa,
my lyrics were not
supposed to be that deep,
but I'm so thankful that it helped you.
- Well, this is the other thing
is like, usually those that,
you know, you felt like a
cocktail napkin and you're like,
look, you know, and then he'd sing it.
And then people were singing
it back and they're like,
what'd you mean? I'm like, I
just had a cocktail napkin.